hello and welcome to teaching and
learning with our studio cloud my name
is mina chatinka randell i am a
professional educator and a data
scientist with our studio as well as a
professor of the practice at duke
university in the statistical science
department i've been teaching and
learning are in our studio for many many
years now and over the last few years
i've really enjoyed being able to teach
with our studio cloud in this webinar i
want to talk to you a little bit about
what our studio cloud is how you can
teach and learn with it and i want to
particularly highlight some of the new
developments in our studio cloud that i
think would be of interest to educators
the webinar will be streamed live on
youtube and i will be also answering
questions during the live stream so if
you think of any questions as we're
going through things please put them in
the chat and i will be there to answer
them and you can also see a link on the
slides rstd.io
tl
rs cloud and that's where you can find
the pdf of the slides as well
so let's start with what is our studio
cloud our studio cloud is a lightweight
cloud-based solution that allows anyone
to do share teach and learn data science
online in the browser
so all you need is a computer with an
internet connection and a browser to be
able to start computing with r you do
not actually need to install anything so
there's nothing to configure gear no
dedicated hardware and no installation
that's what i think makes it really easy
for students to get started with
computing and that's what makes it our
studio cloud an attractive choice for
teaching
so let's uh talk a little bit about our
studio cloud this is what our studio
cloud looks like when you've logged on
so over here you can see a little link
that says new project and i'm going to
click on that and i'm going to select
new rstudio project this takes a second
to deploy a project which is basically
the same as in our studio project i can
give it a name in the web user interface
and the rest of it is basically the
rstudio ide that you're accustomed to
you can see that i can start computing
right away
so let's start by asking the question
why might we want to use our studio in
the cloud
if we are actually teaching with a local
installation
the students when they first come to
class they would need to first install r
and then install our studio and then
maybe install a bunch of packages that
you're going to use then load these
packages if you're teaching with version
control they will also need to install
git
and that has a lot of potential friction
points
maybe some steps are easier than others
but if we were to actually go try to go
through each of these steps with the
audience right now we probably wouldn't
be able to get through it so quickly on
the other hand when you are teaching
with our studio cloud what you can tell
your students is go to our studio cloud
just log in and start coding much less
friction to get started with
so how might you access our studio in
the cloud you have a couple options your
first option is using our studio
workbench which is basically a
professional
product offered by our studio um this
requires that you yourself as an
educator either have some sys admin
experience or you have some i.t support
who can help you set this up you also
need either a hardware to learn this run
this piece of software a local
virtual machine or some cloud computing
credits because
your students are going to be competing
somewhere and that needs to happen
either in the cloud where you're paying
for it or you have credit for it or on a
local hardware
um obviously you also need to have our
studio experience because you are
teaching with our studio
um
if this actually defines you well um our
studio makes our studio workbench
licenses it for free
as part of their academic pricing so you
can go to rstudio.com
pricing slash academic dash pricing and
you can read a little bit about it i
think they want something like a
syllabus to show that you're going to be
using this for teaching and you can get
that and if this is of interest to you
we actually have a paper in the american
statistician called infrastructure and
tools for teaching computing throughout
the statistical curriculum where we go
into the details of how you can set this
up for your students
but as you saw there's lots that's
needed to be able to get started with
this and if you neither have the sis
admin experience or
you don't have the i.t support available
to you this may be a little bit out of
reach
with our studio cloud really all you
need to have is our studio experience
and nothing else so i think that's one
thing that makes it quite attractive as
an educator especially if you're
teaching statistics or data science
you may not have this as admin
experience or you may not have the
resources listed there to be able to run
this stuff locally
um so next question is fine maybe i've
convinced you that teaching your
students um how to use r in our studio
in the cloud is a good idea that they
should be just going to their web
browser and starting doing computing
why are studio cloud then and maybe not
some other option well let's talk about
our studio cloud in a nutshell we
already said that it does not require it
experience to set up it also has some
features designed for teaching for
example you can organize your classes as
a workspace you can leverage roles so
you can have different roles for your
instructor
yourself your teaching assistants or
your students you can turn projects into
assignments which is using vocabulary
your students are familiar with you can
actually peek into student projects
which is hugely helpful when you're
trying to help them out especially
remotely and you can ensure the same
setup for all the student projects using
the concept of a base project that we'll
touch on in a little bit
additionally certain system libraries
work out of the box like you can you
know get started with git without
actually having to install it
and you can knit to pdf and word out of
the box as well um as opposed to having
your students you know having locally
set up something like
latex or
having access to microsoft word
um let's talk a little bit about
projects in our studio cloud which is
basically how we encapsulate our work
and how we organize it there are three
types of projects the first one is the
rstudio project that we have already
seen we had created this project i had
named it my first rstudio project i've
also shown you that you know you can do
plotting and whatnot it's basically the
ide you're familiar with and we're
typing our code here
an alternative is a jupiter project this
is a new feature and it's in beta so
there may be changes to it there will
probably be updates to it we can go to
the same menu and choose a jupiter
project and you can see that you're
basically finding yourself in a jupiter
notebook and you can launch it and you
know you can start running some python
code there as well now you can also run
python code in an arc in the r studio
ide via the reticulate package so this
is not the only way that you could be
using our studio cloud for um teaching
python but
using jupyter notebooks is beyond just
teaching python this is just one example
where you're actually running python
code
additionally you can start a project
from a git repository this is something
i use very regularly because i teach
using git and github
i teach git as a version control uh
system but we also use uh github as kind
of our learning management system every
assignment is a repository for my
students and so they go to github first
grab their private repository that's
named to them and then they bring in the
files that i have put in that repository
to get started that's basically doing a
get clone if you're familiar with that
language um in order to do this in our
studio cloud i can again click on new
project say new project from git and
paste the url of the project i'm going
to
simply clone the praise package that
basically generates some random praise
that you can use in your work or in your
other packages
and you can see that basically we've
cloned that project and i can continue
working with this the our studio id
already provides a get tab for me anyway
as soon as it recognizes that this is a
get version controlled project and i can
start interacting with it that way and
push and pull to github
all right so we've talked about the
three ways that you could be
working in our studio cloud and creating
projects so let's talk a little bit
about teaching with our studio cloud
um i tend to think of my teaching
experiences in one of these uh two kind
of um
types either shorter engagement teaching
or longer engagement teaching what i
mean by shorter engagement teaching is
it's maybe a workshop like a couple
hours a short course at a conference for
four hours or maybe even a full day but
more importantly than time perhaps is
the amount of content where content i
think can be organized in one or just a
few projects that i could share with my
learners and additionally in this kind
of engagement i'm generally not
interested in keeping track of my
learner so i don't have things like have
students completed their homework or
maybe i don't after the teaching
engagement is over
i have a need to go peek into their
project to provide additional support to
them
uh
if this is the case i would recommend
that you use kind of the simpler
approach of just share a single project
with your learners
if we're thinking about a longer
engagement for me that's usually a
semester-long course a multi-day
workshop or something like that and
again from the content perspective where
content can be best organized in
multiple projects
additionally
i want to keep track of my learners i
want to know who my students are i want
to know if they're in my workspace i
want to know if they've started their
work i want to be able to provide
guidance to them by sometimes peeking
into their projects if this defines your
teaching engagement then the approach
where you invite your students to a
workspace where you have organized the
content
is i think a better approach so let's
start with a slightly simpler one where
i said would be i believe better suited
for a shorter engagement teaching in
this case we're sharing in our studio
cloud project and we'll give the example
of a single r studio cloud project but
as i said you know if it's just two or
three of them and you want to share them
individually that's probably not too
confusing for your learners versus in a
longer engagement you might have 10
homework assignments and 10 labs and a
project and whatnot and you probably
don't want to individually share links
for each and every one of those
so
how does this go we're going to be
looking at the instructor view now so i
am in
um i have created on our studio cloud a
single project and i have named it
introduction to shiny you can see that
on the top um left corner of my screen
and you can see that i've created this
project in what is called your workspace
so this is my personal workspace um and
there i've created a
project called introduction to shiny
which let's say is the short course that
i'm going to teach at a conference in
the files tab you can see that i have
created some folders where i've
organized the content so
if we take a look at one of those
folders let's start with the first
module maybe i have some slides i have
an app
in there that the students are going to
work with a few other app examples that
i'm going to teach with
since i'm teaching shiny i definitely
want to install the shiny package
probably other packages too but to keep
things simple
let's also install the shiny package so
in this project i have installed the
shiny package now
and let's also just confirm that it's
been installed one thing i'd like to do
is i just try to load the package does
that work let's do library shiny that
seems to be working okay and i'm gonna
say we're good to go and share this
content with the students so you can see
all the structure for the workshop is
there i'm gonna click on that little
gear icon go to access and for who can
view this project i'm going to say
everyone
and then i am going to go up to the url
and simply copy that link that's it
that's all i need to share this content
with my students and you can see that by
using a nice kind of folder structure
i've been able to organize the material
for them i like naming my folders in
this way so learners know where we're at
at each point of a workshop for example
so i've copied the url
after making the project available to
everyone so soon as i turn that switch
it is you know available to the whole
world although who will be able to find
that uh project id it's very unlikely
that someone can stumble upon it unless
i share the link with them
on the student view now they receive
that url from their instructor and so
they go to their url bar and simply
paste it and what they do is they need
to now log in so they're going to log in
to our studio cloud you can log in with
google for example
and
they can start computing they see the
same folder structure everything that i
gave them is there remember we installed
the shiny package they're able to load
it so they don't have to reinstall it
again that's already there for them they
can see the content i've prepared for
them they could even right away go ahead
and run the app for example um from the
students perspective this is a really
nice way of getting started right we
really didn't have to teach them or at
least spend time during the workshop
which is about introduction to shiny in
this hypothetical case
about how to set things up for them
so let's talk a little bit about this
notion of sharing a single r studio
cloud project to disseminate your
teaching materials on the plus side
students land directly in a project upon
login right they get the url and they're
in your the our studio ide which i think
is perfect it's great for sharing code
in general too so i tend to think about
this approach not just in the context of
teaching but also in the context of
collaboration or you know sometimes you
have this reproducible example that's
not quite minimal um that still perhaps
takes a lot of code and you really want
someone to be able to dive into your
computing environment and see what
you're doing
that's what it's also great for just
being able to share your entire
environment with them
um
on the potentially minus side um i don't
know if your i caught at caught that but
on the top of the window in the stud on
the student view you could see in red
the words temporary copy so students
need to remember to make a permanent
copy of the project you share with them
and they can do that that read uh you
know text blinks that hopefully gets
their attention and there's a little
button right next to it that says save a
permanent copy
but really what i mean by this bullet
point is that it is on you as the
instructor to remind them to do that
because soon as they make a permanent
copy their work will be saved they could
close their browser window they could
lose power it doesn't matter they can
come back and pick up where they left
off however if they have not made the
permanent copy and started working on it
and then they close their window they're
going to actually lose their work and
there's nothing more frustrating to a
student than that so this is totally
avoidable but
you as the instructor
will need to remind them
you can't keep track which students
started their assignments so this url
just goes out into the world and anyone
who has access to that uh can use it but
you don't have a way of monitoring who
have made copies of your project and
started their assignment
if a student wants help from you in a
way where they would want um you to peek
into their project you need to be
granted permission in order to be able
to do that so that's an additional step
for the students to have to do
now there are two other bullet points i
want to discuss and these could be
pluses for some of you and minuses for
others
these permanent projects once a student
makes a permanent project count towards
the students free hours on our studio
cloud
for some this might be okay because
maybe
you
are in teaching in a situation where you
are not
going to be kind of responsible for the
cost of the compute your learners are
going to be so in that case this might
be okay
chances are if you're teaching in a
university setting for example where
students um you know have already paid
for the course and do not expect to
incur additional charges um they
probably would not want to be put in a
situation where they have a limited
number of free hours to work on their
assignment we want students to be work
on their working on uh things as long as
they want to and not have these kind of
artificial limits on their learning
additionally students control
permissions is this a good thing or a
bad thing it again depends if you're
teaching in a graded course you may not
want this because it's a too easy a way
perhaps for them to um
share their work with their classmates
which might constitute some sort of
academic misconduct
but you might be teaching in a little
workshop where this is perfectly fine so
again depending on your situation these
could be pros or or cons
let's talk also about inviting to an
rstudio cloud workspace which is the
second method of sharing your materials
that i mentioned um which is for longer
engagement projects
so
here what we're going to do on the
instructor view is you can see this is
my account i have a bunch of projects to
myself in my workspace but i'm going to
click on the little um kind of hamburger
menu there open the sidebar and create a
new space let's say i'm teaching a
longer workshop called shiny essentials
this was a two day workshop i taught
this year so i figured i'd reuse that
name
and here i can see there's nothing in
that workspace yet i can create a new
rstudio project and i can name it uh
something maybe let's just name it 01
getting started again say that's going
to be the first module
in this particular longer workshop that
i'm giving
so here again we have an rstudio cloud
project and i can change the access
level to everyone but this time it's not
everyone in the world it's everyone in
this workspace and i'm going to turn it
into an assignment so now when the
students get invited to my workspace and
land here they're going to see that they
have some assignments they need to start
working on this is not to say it's like
homework it's just something they can
get started with and in fact on the
student view they see the word start
instead of the word assignment there
um you can see uh from a different uh so
a workshop that i actually did give that
was uh designed in this way for each of
the assignments that i have created i
can see the derived project so i could
actually click on there and peek into
students projects
and this is a good way the summary
statistics here are a good way of
gauging for you how many students have
started but also you can deep down dive
deeper and look into their projects
which is really nice especially if they
need help and you're teaching remotely
and can't just kind of peek over their
shoulder
in the members tab of a workspace that
you create like this you have some
options you have some options about how
you want to invite students to your
workspace i generally use the sharing
link so it creates a single link and i
can pick a role for people who come into
the workspace using that link and we'll
say more about the roles in a second and
simply either email that out or if i'm
teaching you know share that during the
first few minutes of the teaching
engagement
i've covered some names up here to in
order not to show um the real students
names on the webinar but you can
basically see that that would be how you
can keep track of who is in your
workspace
so the four roles that are available are
admin moderator contributor and viewer
and they have different permission
levels so admin is probably you and you
can do everything including managing
users
a moderator is usually the level of
access i give my teaching assistants
they can view and
edit and manage all projects so they can
go in and help students but they don't
end up managing the users the actual
students who get admitted into the place
contributors are basically students who
can only see their work
and then
viewers
i generally use that for like an auditor
in a course or sometimes a guest like a
colleague will say i'd like to see how
you're doing things but i don't
necessarily want them to see the list of
students you know in my course in the um
in the members tab so i give them that
lowest level of access
um we can also set permissions these
boxes will be unchecked by default and i
would be encourage you to be carefully
thinking about checking them so do you
want your contributors to see the
members list you know if you're teaching
a public course maybe not maybe if it's
a small university course and you want
everyone to know each other's names
maybe you do
whether or not contributors so that
students can make their projects visible
to all members again we discuss this
notion of potential
academic misconduct that could happen by
students
being able to too easily share their
work perhaps you know not checking that
box is not going to protect you from you
know everything that could go wrong but
we don't want to potentially be
additionally making things easy for
students if the way the course is set up
is um such that they shouldn't see each
other's work or if it is that they
should be able to then we could allow
them to change that and the third one is
about whether they can change project
resources and that's getting into things
like the memory and the compute that
they're going to use which gets tied
into the pricing which we'll say a
couple things about at the very end
so think about these permission levels
but it's good to know that these are
there that you and you can toggle uh
based on your own teaching situation
um we also mentioned this notion of a
base project so here in the workspace
i've clicked on the gear icon for the
workspace itself where i could rename my
course if i wanted to but underneath it
you can see that i can set a base our
studio project so these base projects
include they're basically an any old our
studio cloud project that you kind of
delegate as the base project
this is where you can define the r
version that will be used for all
projects what packages will be installed
and if there's any certain files that
you want repeated across all of the
projects in the course for me this is
usually not data because i usually tend
to change you know data files from
assignment to assignment but it's
usually things like a code of conduct
maybe submission instructors things that
will stay constant throughout the
assignment
and you can update it as many times as
you like which is really great because
if you you know if there's a new package
comes out or a package gets updated and
you want to change things up in the
middle of the semester you can go back
and do that and your changes are not
retroactive for a good reason you don't
want to mess up students work that
happen prior to that time point so any
changes you make will only affect
projects that are created after that
change was made
so inviting nrc inviting your students
to an rcdo cloud workspace lots of
pluses in my opinion various permission
levels this notion of base projects with
desired packages installed the notion of
assignments which remove the need to
remind students to make a copy of the
project before starting work
and this ability to peek into student
projects
maybe on the minus side one thing i can
think of is that when students land in
the workspace they don't actually land
in the r studio id right they need to do
an additional thing to figure out which
project to go into next so they may need
instructions like start the assignment
titled getting started or something like
that
easy enough to handle but something you
need to remember as the instructor
and again on could be a pro could be a
con site student's work now counts
towards yours you know this could be you
as an instructor or your institution
that might be paying for the particular
level of our studio cloud for the
workspace hours and that could be a
positive or it could be a negative
depending on your situation
an instructor controls the permissions
and again depending on the teaching
engagement type you have
that may be a positive or a negative i
tend to find that for my university
teaching these are both pros for me uh
but for other types of teaching
engagements that might be different
let's wrap things up with a few tips for
teaching with our studio cloud so
one the first is that when you changes
to an assignment student has started one
propagate to student copy so if you've
set up an assignment for your students
and then realize there was a typo or you
forgot to add a data file
you're not going to be able to just
change things up and then let it
propagate once the students start their
assignment they're actually making a
copy of that assignment like at that
snapshot of time point um so you're
going to need to get that information to
them in some other way if you're
teaching with git you could be updating
the github repositories and they could
simply pull the changes from there
otherwise maybe you reach out to your
students in some other way to let them
know of the corrections
packages in the base project are
installed but they're not loaded so
don't forget those library commands and
the assignments that you give to the
students
the latest information is always on the
rstudio cloud guide and the what's new
page and you can get to these from the
hamburger menu on the um left side of
your rstudio cloud window so if you're
thinking how do i do x the guide is
probably the first place to look at
and if you encounter any sort of
slowness or glitches you know projects
not starting up as quickly as they used
to the first place to check is the
system status so you can take a again
you can from the left hand uh menu you
can get under help to the current system
status and if there is an outage that
will be noted there if there isn't but
you're still experiencing this or your
students are experiencing it then um you
know reach out to support
to let them know
um
if you i would strongly recommend
creating an additional account and log
in as a student to see what they see
because what you see is not always what
they see and it's nice to be able to
assure yourself that you've set things
up the right way especially the first
few times you're teaching with a new
technology
test assignments to set sufficient
computational resources these are
toggles that you can
change
so you can see those little toggles on
the side here so make sure that you test
to make sure that you know the data side
size you have or the computation you're
asking your students will actually work
with the allocated kind of ram and the
cpus and if not you will be able to
toggle those up if you want
um the whole peeking at your students
project feature is fantastic
but
you i believe you might want to use that
sparingly or at least i try to use that
sparingly because the first thing that i
want to get my students to do is to
learn to articulate the issues they're
having without me going in and fixing it
for them that being said sometimes they
may not have the right vocabulary if
they're for especially if they're you
know very new to computing to r to our
studio so it's nice to be able to you
know push them to articulate these but
if that's not getting anywhere and
people are getting frustrated or the
students is getting frustrated it's
really nice to be able to peek in and
it's additionally helpful for remote
teaching situations as you can imagine
um the assignment feature even though
the word is assignment i try not to
think of it as just homework i also try
to think of it as you know if i'm going
to be doing some live coding in class
i'd like to write out a skeleton for
myself um where i will be filling in the
code and i use that feature to share
that code starter with the students so
that some of them if they actually want
to code along with me they have that to
get started with
a couple other useful resources
there is now a nice playlist with 14
very short and informative videos about
how to do much of what i talked about
and more with our studio cloud and
there's a short link for it on the top
of the
screen rstd.io
cloud dash playlist so you can take a
look at those and watch through them
and if you are going to be using our
studio cloud for teaching or for other
purposes where you think there will be
heavy usage lots of students
or maybe
lots of projects take a look at the
pricing options there is always a free
option although
as soon as you're thinking about a
classroom with a substantial number of
students the free option may not be the
right one for you may not be sufficient
anymore so i would recommend especially
taking a look at the cloud instructor um
pricing plan and also reaching out to
the r studio sales folks who work on
this to just describe your situation of
number of students and the type of
course you're teaching to let them help
you help guide you to figure out the
best pricing option for you
thank you very much for tuning in and i
will hang out a little bit in the chat
on youtube as well to answer your
questions
once again you can find the slides at
rstd.io
tl-rs cloud if you'd like to see a pdf
version of those as well have a great
day